ftx and sam bankman freed are coming
after robin hood
it had got announced yesterday that sam
bankman free the ceo of ftx exchange
bought 56.3 million shares of robin hood
and now owns nearly 8
of the company this is a massive deal i
mean look at sam right there chilling in
his little bean bag so sam for you guys
that don't know is the ceo of ftx it's a
multi multi multi multi billion dollar
company he has done extremely well uh
throughout the last few years as crypto
has become a mainstream asset and gained
trillions of dollars of value he owns
the exchange and now he is acquiring
shares in robinhood which is
traditionally an equity brokerage uh but
they have transitioned now and now most
of their trading actually comes through
crypto so if we look at the stats of
robinhood it's actually a pretty big
business they went public a few
different a few months ago and now they
have millions of accounts and they're
doing millions of millions of dollars in
volume so at the end of 2021 they had
22.7 million users a year-over-year
increase of 81 so the platform is
growing pretty fast and they have no
commission trading right so they do the
payment for order flow that you guys
have become accustomed to or or at least
learned about over the last few years
and the importance that it has on the
market they lost 3.7 billion dollars in
2021 and revenue fell 43 in the first
quarter of 2022 from a year ago so i
don't have the numbers in front of me
but a lot of that is actually due to
crypto because these businesses with no
fee trading they're making majority of
their money on the crypto now and that's
why exchanges like robinhood have gotten
so aggressive with marketing right so
when you think about robin hood uh it
used to be hey we do no commission and
that's the way they pitch it to everyone
else right come trade your your stocks
here and you'll get a good deal now it's
become hey here's doge here's sheave and
here she been all these other things and
it's turned into this crypto s platform
where they're doing a little bit of
everything but the majority of their
trading actually comes from crypto
versus stocks now so we don't know
exactly what sam beckman fred is doing
here he hasn't publicly said his
intentions uh he is a passive investor
at this point he's not an active
investor the the
two founders of the company still own
the majority of the business and would
have voting rights over him at this
point but i do think it's interesting
that the ceo of a massive crypto
exchange is now buying what you would
consider a traditional uh brokerage or
traditional equity brokerage that has
now transitioned into crypto so i think
it's a massive thing to watch but
ultimately i don't know what we what we
know will come out of it what is your
opinion john robin hood just
missed big on their expectations what
they were gonna do in revenue they have
clearly leaned more and more towards
crypto to your point about how they
initially got i would call it popularity
because of all the meme stock craze that
was happening in 2020 during the
pandemic people are at home trying to
learn what to do they leaned heavily on
crypto crypto increased a lot in prices
we've seen this across the board with
all exchanges in crypto that their 20 22
q1 numbers that are coming out aren't as
spectacular as people thought because
they're leaning so heavily on an asset
that has gone down a lot in value with
that said sam pegman freed worth 11
billion dollars um buying part i'll call
it eight percent seven percent eight
percent of robin hood is great for
robinhood it's probably great for sam
bankman free they've gotten a lot of
users they've obviously retracted that
number because they've leaned so heavily
on crypto but they've gotten a lot of
users sam beckman freed i'm sure would
love to get more involved in the retail
trader aspect of things as ftx is a
little bit more kind of geared for
professional traders um so his
platform's a little different but yeah
good for him i mean robin hood i i am a
little bit bullish on robin hood i think
they have a good opportunity to capture
a lot more of the market share to get a
lot more people especially the younger
generation they gamified the app i like
the move for sam bankman freed
now this is exactly what happened with
twitter does he stay passive investor
does he immediately just get aggressive
and try to buy the business yeah so what
is the value let me look it up real
quick the valuation of uh of robin well
you can see that it went up about 30
percent after hours so it's a 10 billion
business from a market cap perspective
uh right now and that's a after a 25
increase right so uh sam bankman free
bought the position or the position got
announced yesterday it's up 25 today
alone robin hood stock it's now a 9.34
billion dollar business so sam has
plenty of money and can can have access
to the capital markets to get plenty of
more money if he wanted to acquire a
meaningful position in the business i
mean he already has a meaningful
position but a larger position
but i do think it's interesting because
if i remember correctly i think the
stock ipo'd uh it went public yeah it
went public in the 30s 35 it traded on
its first day and it shot all the way up
to 55 and it's down uh even with the sam
bankman free bump it's still down 80
percent so it's been a rough few months
for robin hood as a company in the
public markets and i think what we've
seen is like sam probably thinks that he
can do a bunch of different things
around the success that he's had with
ftx and change dropping it up to have
success there and they have a massive
customer base right so at some point
you're paying for that attention you're
paying for that access to a whole
younger generation and fcx has done a
lot of these different things through
marketing and so forth with sports and
entertainment and stuff like that on the
financial side but i think robin hood
probably represents an asset to him that
is extremely valuable i don't know if
it's worth 10 billion dollars i don't
know if it's worth more or less than
that to him but he obviously sees value
in the position that he's that he's
garnered from an equity perspective and
it wouldn't be surprising to me to see
him do something similar to what elon
has done at twitter right which is go in
acquire a position in the business go
from passive to active and then figure
out how you can
take control the business
sam is uh extremely wealthy personally
he has built a large position the ftx is
obviously a large business he has access
to the financial capital now he's raised
billions of dollars at ftx from
investors he certainly could go do it if
he wanted to and buy robin hood i don't
know if that's happening i don't know if
he just wants to implement some changes
i don't know if there's another game
here that he's playing uh but ultimately
it wouldn't surprise me if this is just
the start of this story with him
we're gonna see i think he uh he could
pull basically what
elon did with twitter which is you make
that small investment and then you
almost strong-arm them and say look i
have the money to do it i'm going to buy
you guys this is what's going to happen
if you deny me of buying you guys at a
premium it's clearly against the
interest of your shareholders because
they will actually get more value for
their dollar as it currently sits i
think we actually might see something
similar but there's no 100 guarantee in
anything